le comento que el presidente Pedro
Castillo se mostró muy agradecido y
contento de que los mandatarios de la
alianza del Pacífico vengan a hacer una
muy probable reunión pronto para
entregarle la presidencia protemporé del
bloque regional al mandatario peruano y
que después se realice una cumbre de
presidentes de Chile Colombia y México
Pedro Castillo ha señalado esta
dispuesto a recibir a los presidentes de
la alianza del Pacífico los espera con
los brazos abiertos si es que ellos
desean realizar una visita anticipada en
los siguientes días ha señalado hay que
recordar que el pasado jueves 17 de
noviembre el congreso peruano le negó al
mandatario peruano una visita a México
para esta importante Cumbre esto ha
motivado que el presidente mexicano
Manuel López Obrador decidiera Cancelar
esta importante Cumbre hay que señalar
de otro lado que Pedro Castillo enfrenta
una crisis política que ya lleva varios
meses en este país
también tiene
sobre sus hombros El Seis acusaciones
por corrupción y la verdad que este
hecho que vengan los presidentes en
México Colombia y chile representa para
Pedro Castillo un respaldo internacional
en momentos en que más lo necesita y
Francisco como avanza la misión de la
oea que Investiga a petición de Castillo
esta crisis a que usted nos reporta
entre el legislativo y El Ejecutivo
Sí justamente la comisión de alto nivel
de la organización de los Estados
Americanos atendiendo a la activación de
la carta democrática Interamericana está
llevando su segundo día de reuniones en
la cual esta cita culmina hoy en este
país y hasta el momento se ha reunido
con los integrantes del gobierno del
presidente Pedro Castillo los líderes
del parlamento peruano en la jefa del
poder judicial así como la fiscal
general de Perú entre otras integrantes
de la sociedad civil peruana el
presidente del poder legislativo José
Williams ha reconocido que existe
fricciones con el gobierno de Pedro
Castillo Pero ha negado que el
parlamento peruano esté tratando de
producir un golpe de estado en este país
para derrocarlo por su parte Pedro
Castillo le ha dicho a la comisión de
alto nivel que él mantendrá el diálogo
permanente con todas las instituciones
del país para tratar de solucionar esta
crisis que mantiene paralizada esta
nación hay que señalar también que El
Vocero del grupo alto nivel el audio
loyzaga ha afirmado que los diálogos son
transparentes y que las conclusiones
serán dadas a conocer a la comisión
permanente de la oea en los próximos
días